well immigration listen to this just
overtook inflation As Americans top
concern right now as voters in New
Hampshire head to the polls it's pretty
big a new Harvard Harris poll meanwhile
shows concerns over the Border topping
Rising prices the economy and crime as
well and the Supreme Court just handed
the Biden Administration a win may not
be a win politically but a win legally
for certain on immigration yesterday the
Court's ruling will allow border patrol
agents to cut the razor wire that Texas
installed to try and stop the
unprecedented surge of migrants the
ruling escalates a political battle
between Texas governor Greg Abbott in
the White House over how to protect our
Southern border Texas governor Greg
Abbott warning this is not over I will
continue to defend Texas's
constitutional authority to secure the
border and prevent the Biden admin from
destroying our property Emily I want to
make clear here the Biden Administration
this is not something that is happening
to them this is something they are
choosing to allow to happen the
immigration and nationality act says in
no uncertain terms that the Attorney
General shall detain certain groups of
migrants they're not doing it and then
January 2nd you had the solicitor
general of the Biden Administration say
to the Supreme Court it's time to stop
Texas and let's walk through what that
looked like Kaye so Texas put up razor
wire to try to defend herself against
the millions of illegal immigrants that
are flooding across her border depleting
that state of resources of finances of
energies of of the priority that has
been consistently maintained over and
over again as Rock Bottom in this
administration's eyes so Texas dared to
try to protect herself and then the
Biden Administration came in and started
cutting the wire so the Attorney General
of Texas sued saying hey Administration
Federal please stop doing this let me
protect myself now this ruling from the
Supreme Court has to do with the
injunction while it's on appeal it means
that the Supreme Court said while we are
waiting for an official opinion from the
lower courts we are going to allow you
Biden to keep cutting that wire and
let's let's go back to a quote from the
attorney general kayy as it was released
he said this to Fox News digital we'll
put it up on the screen here he said the
Supreme Court's temporary order allows
Biden to continue his illegal effort to
Aid the foreign invasion of America the
destruction of Texas's border will not
help enforce the law or keep American
citizens safe this fight is not over I
look forward to defending our state
sovereignty let me tell you what the
Biden Administration argued this is this
is the irony the Biden Administration
argued that the reason that it had to
cut down the wire is because the wires
were impeding the federal agents from
doing their job you know what the
Department of Homeland Security said
after this ruling they came out and
essentially said oh good now we can go
back to doing our job of enforcing the
law
but I think that every single state I
think the hundreds of thousands of
Americans who have lost loved ones to
fentel including many people watching
this show I think the mayors that are at
Arms watching their citizens or taxpayer
citizens being displaced by illegal
immigrants main watching their citizens
enjoy buildings that are built
specifically for illegal immigrants
while giving them free rent free iPhones
the list goes on of the destruction that
that somehow is what the federal
government is saying that's them doing
their job so Bravo to attorney general
and the governor for continuing their
fight but at the moment unfortunately
it's a losing it's a losing for the
battle but hopefully a win for the war
in the long run yeah and meanwhile vice
president kamla Harris deployed on the
airwaves last night to carry the
immigration talking points let's
watch well
so there is no question that our
immigration system is broken but sadly
people on the other side of the aisle
have been playing politics with this
issue issue the solutions are at
hand
and you know gone are the days sadly
where a President Bush or John
McCain understood that we should have a
bipartisan approach to fixing this
problem which is a long-standing
problem you know fact check vice
president Harris as I come to you Harris
fauler there were 89 executive actions
the Biden Administration took to roll
back Trump's actions and by the way I
seem to remember Democrats controlling
Congress when they said that they
couldn't pass an immigration bill yeah
uh they had by Camal uh leadership both
houses they had the White House and they
still couldn't get it done which begs
the question who backed away um KLA
Harris needs to to take a look at that
like when it was on their watch and
within their own hands they couldn't get
it done or didn't want to um I have 11
cousins in the Dallas Metro I have a lot
of family in Texas and my other border
home state is my husband's where he was
born and raised and that's in Arizona I
have a lot of
family that that watches this happen
every day and wonders who cares about
those States enough to make them feel
like they're part of the American United
States who cares because it doesn't seem
like it would be the man in the white
house or anybody who he's tasked with
fixing it so if they aren't going to
take care of it at a federal level if
Alejandro mayorcas is the Homeland
secretary uh security secretary is going
to lose 85,000 to 100,000 of locations
for migrant children don't know what we
did with that many as they came across
the if all of that is going to continue
to happen then these states have to do
their jobs to protect our Citizens We're
all one country the government the
federal government may not see us that
way like they're at the head of the
snake and then we're just on the ground
no it's the other way around we're in
control as American citizens and we have
every right in our states to want our
local governments our state governments
and to expect them to take care of us so
the White House has now got a prove do
they love us or not if not then just get
out of the way and let us let us protect
our own people right because let's be
clear Americans are dying because of our
poorest Southern border his here's Rick
Harrison his son just passed away from a
fental
overdose he said this to the New York
Post yes I can confirm Adam died from a
fenel overdose the fenel crisis in this
country must be taken more seriously it
seems it is just flowing over the
borders and nothing is being done about
it we must do better sha Duffy I heard
last week Ambassador Nikki Haley say she
was at a town hall event where a mom in
that town hall event in that moment lost
her son to a fenel overdose she came
back to an event a week later with tears
in her eyes and said I wanted to share
this story because I wanted to know that
this would mean something to someone and
someone would fix it Shan
Duffy yeah they overdoses or the
poisonin from Fentanyl and and the
problem is it appears that Joe Biden
doesn't seem to care tens of thousands
of American families have lost loved
ones and to your point you said that uh
Joe Biden took you know what how many
executive orders to to overturn Trump
policies but on top of that he went to
the Supreme Court to make sure that they
can cut the wire and tear down the
barriers that Texas have put up to
secure the Border they've done
everything they can to make sure this
border is open and Fentanyl flows in
beg's a question what's up with Amy Cony
Barrett uh has she drinken the DC water
and become now a liberal I get that from
Justice Tom uh justice Robert but ity
con Barrett now now making sure that she
can fight Texas and keep the Border open
but you mentioned polling right so this
is the top issue and it's not just
Republicans what 81% of Republicans
believe this is the top issue but half
of Democrats believe this is a top issue
immigration but after that you have
inflation and then you have um jobs in
the economy these are all top rated
issues for the Republican Party Joe
Biden is failing at the top three issues
that Americans care about at 7% comes in
abortion which is what Jo Biden's going
to run on not a good straty not a good
strategy Molly there's one party that
has done something about this and let's
scroll it hr2 this is what Republicans
passed restarting the border wall
construction adding border agents to the
southern border you can see the list
right there so when you say Republicans
haven't taken action this bill could be
passed today by the United States
Senate yeah we'll see ultimately what
happens with that but I think you and
Sean have both raised some great points
in the last couple of minutes regarding
uh the fent and Fentanyl overdoses
Across America it's been hitting
particularly hard in New Hampshire in
the granite state where voters are at
the polls right now talking about this
issue and New Hampshire is in fact a
border state they have about 58 miles of
border with the northern border with
Canada they're in the swaton sector uh
the headlight over the summer where that
there was a ten-fold increase in
Crossings on the northern border we
don't pay as much attention up there but
that also includes some of the folks
that were caught that are on the terror
watch list Governor sonunu tried to do
something about this in the fall calling
on on the federal government to step in
and also to allow them locally to do
more they've put $1.4 million into this
in a task force uh they in the northern
border and it's something both fenel and
this border issue that New Hampshire
voters are caring about and we may see
that at the polls it's an absolute
tragedy Molly line thank you hey
everyone I'm Emily compano catch me and
my co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaye
mechineni on outnumbered every week day
at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or sets your DVR
also don't forget to subscribe to the
fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights